foreign
[Music]
for Tuesday January 10th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
so many tech companies have announced
layoffs in recent months last week
Amazon said its planned Cuts would
affect 18 000 workers mostly in its
corporate ranks and Salesforce said it
would trim 10 of its staff Cuts have
also been announced by Facebook parent
meta Twitter snap online real estate
firm Redfin video company Vimeo Uber
Lyft Netflix the list goes on and on
it's a big reversal for a sector that
was hiring quickly during the pandemic
and to be fair many of the laid off
workers are finding new jobs quickly and
unemployment across the U.S remains low
but the cuts take it all together May
signal a shift in how tech companies set
their priorities going forward with us
to discuss this change is our reporter
Dana mattioli hi Dana thanks for being
here anytime so before we get into what
all of this means for the tech sector
can you take us back a bit what is Tech
hiring been like over over the last few
years
over the last few years Tech hiring has
been a frenzy it's been
a major engine of job growth in the
country and these tech companies that
are flush with cash had been throwing
these very lucrative pay packages at
employees and engineers and really
bidding up the market like really very
expensive pay packages with stock
options and the like so it's almost like
a lot of them had this carte blanche
when it came to hiring
all right but now there are all these
layoffs that are happening what are some
of the factors that have led to this
reversal
over the last few months Tech CEOs have
become much more cautious so there's
been chatter of a potential recession on
the horizon there's talk of battening
down the hatches and you know their
clients are starting to slow their
spending and their clients are in Tech
but also other Industries and they're
trying to shore up their balance sheets
right so they're seeing some
cautiousness from their own clients
maybe pulling back spending and also
they're having to answer to their
investors in a different way for a very
long time the tech sector has been
growth above everything that's in their
mindset right grow at all costs and now
the tone is changing where these CEOs
are talking more about profits and
they're getting pressure from either
their Venture capitalists that are
backing them or if they're public
they're public investors that want to
see free cash flow and good balance
sheets some of the passes that they've
gotten historically it seems to have
dried up
what are the CEOs and top Executives at
companies then saying about having to
make these cuts are they taking any
responsibility for example for maybe
hiring too much in the past they are and
I think it's important to get into what
covid was like for a lot of these
companies right so covid sets in and
companies like Amazon and Salesforce and
you know even Facebook saw unprecedented
demand for their products and services
people were home people were online more
so their business lines were just flush
with people bombarding it sometimes at
like record numbers right so they had to
really hire to answer that demand but
there was a gnawing feeling in the back
of a lot of their minds that the party
would stop at some point but they didn't
want to miss out on those revenues in
the interim and now what you're seeing
is as each company announces their
layoffs there's like this CEO Mia culpa
where they're saying sorry we added too
quickly we added too much we have to
sort of right size our businesses so
we're seeing that across the board we're
talking about a lot of big tech
companies is this also affecting smaller
ones in startups as well it is it's
affecting both um I think on the startup
side the VCS are starting to get a
little bit nervous about company cost
being out of whack and they really want
their portfolio companies to shore up
their finances and work more on
profitability than growth so we're
seeing that both in the public companies
but also at the startup side we have a
quote from Excel which is a prominent
venture capitalist saying the bull
market in 2022 was in humility that
these CEOs that you know I think
sometimes are characterized as arrogant
in or Brash how to be more humble in how
they're approaching this
Elon has had some of the biggest and
most notable layoffs what has Andy jassy
the company's CEO said about those yeah
so I sat down with Andy jassy last month
to talk through some of this and a few
things he said so one of the areas that
there have been cuts at Amazon are the
devices or the Alexa business which was
Jeff bezos's baby this was an area that
was high growth and very expensive and
they've had to make some tough decisions
there and he said that he still believes
in that device's business but he said at
the same time there's a number of
experiments that they were running in
that area that just looked like they
weren't going to move the needle enough
and it wouldn't justify the cost that
they were spending on that area and what
about companies like say Redfin one that
has already had layoffs and then had to
do another round of layoffs after that
what did they say about having to do
this twice
yeah so uh their CEO Glenn Coleman he
has some regrets about the way this went
down but they added all these Realtors
and they went into different business
lines during covid and I think the big
lesson he said that he learned was the
simplest way to build a profitable
company isn't to come up with amazing
new ideas to Delight customers he says
it's to stop doing stupid stuff right so
I think if he were to go back he
wouldn't have expanded into different
business lines he would just like focus
on what he does well execute and not get
distracted you're mentioning that both
Jazzy and kelman are mentioning pulling
back from business lines that were maybe
a little more experimental or were off
their essential beat is that what more
tech companies are going to have to do
are they just focusing up on their Core
Business going forward I think it might
be a little too soon to tell we did see
you know Snapchat also pull back from
some of its more moonshot sorts of
projects because you know these
moonshots that Silicon Valley is known
for are expensive they're big bets that
oftentimes don't make it so I wouldn't
be surprised in the coming months or a
year those you know aren't as
prioritized as they would have been in
the past what is this going to mean then
for the tech sector going forward you
know it's tough to say I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw a few quarters of
austerity where these companies that are
you know sort of synonymous with perks
and lavishness and big pay packages
start looking a little bit more like
traditional public companies that have
to answer to Wall Street and investors
it's too soon to say if that sticks
right I guess time will tell but in the
interim it seems like these companies
are going to start behaving like more
Normal public companies all right that's
our reporter Dana mattioli thanks for
joining us Dana anytime and that's it
for today's Tech news briefing for more
Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening